like some of it why are you finally ice
to meet you - thanks for coming in I
think actually trolled your show I'm
sure you do you and I figured the
rapper's name did a problematic like rap
or something on cultural appropriation I
trigger you definitely didn't know it
was kind of funny you thought that the
video was funny or trolling it was funny
both oh yeah success so what is a I
use it just to mean beta week I use it
very no I would call you beta I would
say your baby so I'm not all the way a
beta is just a non-aggressive
maybe a little bit passive of a man yeah
and with this kind of stuff
then we'll respect for a cup or a beta
then ignore me like at least that's
something
no normies great Norman's just like they
don't get it for example I don't do
satire anymore why not
Norman's not parking so good at it whoa
it's a little do you hate the left
definitely not that's why we're having a
conversation I usually say no I say I've
turned down the daily show I've turned
down everybody and I appreciate right
here I always say no to TV because all
you people want to do is edit things on
the context I'll give you my word we
would never edit you out of context like
that that's not the kind of show we do
here what's what's the most cuck thing
you've ever done I've had sex Bill
Clinton with a strap-on oh yeah beeps
beeps all right what do you hope to
accomplish long term I like the idea of
sucking Hitler's penis it's on the truck
okay there are things that I said or
done I've been mean to people
gratuitously you know I wish I hadn't
done that so when people are mean to me
I just do that as karma yeah what's the
soundtrack of the all right
I like house music
[Music]
how Gillian dialectic hold your show
dialectic thanks for coming in Mike
[Applause]